welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google Cloud my name is sergei
sukarenko and the product manager for
cloud dataflow and today we'll be
talking about advancing serverless data
processing in cloud dataflow introducing
distributed travel you can ask questions
anytime on the platform you have Googler
standing by ready to answer them let's
get started I wanted to spend just a few
minutes talking about cloud dataflow and
what it does we are a industry-leading
platform for service team and badge data
processing customers users because we
provide unified batch and steaming data
processing capabilities and we offer
them in a server less fully managed way
so that customers don't have to worry
about managing infrastructure we have a
open source program model it's called
Apache Beam and customers also enjoy the
ability to the users when they only have
maybe a few records per second Steam's
and ranging up to millions of queries
per second when the team went ahead and
thought about how to better improve
called data flow and simplify the data
processing challenges that our customers
faced we realized we needed to really
texture our data processing
infrastructure actually the way that the
industry is doing data processing and to
explain why we needed this Rilke tech
chure let me tell you a quick story how
did the industry solve the problem of
processing really large data sets so
imagine it's the year 2000 and we have 1
petabyte of data that you want to
process well Who am I kidding in the
year 2000 a terabyte size data set would
be considered really large so what do
you do if it's the year 2000 and we have
one terabyte of data to process you'd
probably use a large mainframe or a UNIX
box remember it's the year 2000 and you
would use Sam or storage area network
storage that was attached to this big
mainframe as time progressed and new
technologies became available
for example MapReduce you would switch
to a cluster of cheap Linux nodes where
a storage was actually part of the box
and then as things moved to the cloud
you would still use your cheap Linux
infrastructure for CPU but you would
switch to network attached storage in
2010 Google published the Dremel paper
which introduced a novel concept of
processing large volumes of data by
using distributed storage and compute
clusters and in 2011 we launched
bigquery our flagship data warehouse
that was based on the drama concept
bigquery had a replicated and
distributed storage it also had a highly
available compute cluster but they also
had something that the original Dremel
paper didn't mention and that's the
distributed in memory shuffle tier that
connected both storage and compute so
the question becomes why did bigquery
introduce this distributed shuffle tier
what was it that caused them to to care
so much about shuffle well let's answer
the question first what is shuffle
imagine you have a very large data set
and it's a key value base data set we
have key value pairs if the data set is
reasonably sized or small in size you
can probably group in join this data set
by sorting it and doing it in memory
either on this box that single box that
you have or on disk now if your data set
is actually exceeding the capacity of a
single processing node you have to
distribute the processing and sorting
over multiple processing nodes and then
it becomes tricky what you want to
basically end up having is a sorted set
of your data by key where keys are
assigned to particular processing nodes
and all the records related to these
keys are co-located on the same physical
machine and in the process of sorting
you're going to be and going to be
ending in a shuffle operation where
records are physically moved from the
work says they don't belong to two
locations where where they belong to
basically sorted by key and this is what
a shuffle process does now
bigquery processes large volumes of data
and it does it in a distributed way so
it made sense for them to optimize the
shuffle step because it's such a as you
can imagine such a resource intensive
and time intensive step in cloud
dataflow in my product we have very
similar needs and our customers have
very similar challenges they want to
group and join data and we are doing it
we're dealing with large datasets and so
we have to deal it deal with it in a
distributed way we indeed therefore we
ask ourselves the question can we apply
similar concepts of a distributed
shuffle to our own pipelines I wanted to
walk you through through the life of a
batch cloud dataflow pipeline as you
submit it to the dataflow service what
happens when you actually send this job
to our service on the left-hand side I
have the graph of the cloud dataflow a
cloud dataflow pipeline it's what we
call a director cyclical graph with
stages and edges connecting these stages
as data flows from top to bottom on the
right hand side I have a more simplified
representation of this graph we have
data sources we have data
transformations these are the green
boxes they can be either filtering or
projections aggregations we also have
join and group by operations and we have
sinks data sinks into which we write
results so what happens if you submit
this job to the cloud dataflow service
well first off we're going to create a
cluster of processing nodes and then
we're going to start reading from data
sources and as we read the the
information or data elements from data
sources we're going to start applying
data transformations on them we're going
to be doing the filtering the
projections the aggregations once we hit
the joints and the group buys we can
initiate a shuffle operation and use
persistent disk volumes that are
attached to your processing nodes
now at the end we're going to write into
our sinks data sings and shut down this
processing cluster in theta flow as I
said before we're dealing with large
volumes of data and very similarly to
bigquery we wanted to optimize the
interactions between our compute and
storage facilities so we introduced
recently a separate distributed in
memory shuffle component in data flow
and maybe made it completely transparent
to users as a user you continue writing
your pipelines and you don't think about
whether you want to do shuffle in a
distributed way or in any other way you
just specify a parameter that you want
to use a dataflow shuffle component and
we'll take care at take care from from
there let's explain the architects plane
the architecture of our service our user
code is still running on a computer
cluster and this compute cluster is
connected through a very large and fast
pedable network to the data shuffle data
for shuffle component the data for
shuffle is deployed in multiple GCP
regions taking care of regional
availability in the regions where we
don't have shuffle deployed you can
still do shuffle operations you're just
going to be using the persistent disk
shuffle operations available today but
in the regions where we are deployed we
have several components which take care
of the shuffle job first off we have the
auto zone placement component this
component is is responsible for picking
the regional zone in which to run your
shuffle job it will it will pick the
zone based on the available capacity and
closeness to your data sources and sinks
now once the zone is picked the shuffle
proxy will start interacting with the
code that is this part of your data flow
pipeline in as part of this interaction
the shuffle proxy will accept data set
that you want to shuffle and then either
pick the in-memory file system if you
dataset fits entirely into memory or it
will partially distribute data between
the in-memory and the on disk file
system
if the data set is too large to be fair
to fit into memory entirely this is all
transparent to users our developers they
don't have to decide how much data is
going to be shuffled on discourses how
much data is going to be shuffled in
memory we take care of all the
processing one benefit of this approach
is that many customers reporting they're
seeing performance improvements from
from from the three architecture so if
in the past a pipeline that use
persistent disk shuffle might have taken
you 4550 minutes to process a certain
data set and if after some tuning and
using SSD position disks you might have
reduced this time down to perhaps 20
minutes with data flow shuffle the
processing time of such a pipeline is
now closer to ten minutes the results
will not apply uniformly to every
pipeline in production but these are
approximate performance improvements
that we are hearing from a lot of our
customers another benefit of dataflow
shuffle is that we are now able to scale
to much larger data sets in the past we
have persistent disk based shuffle you
were able perhaps shuffle maybe a 50
terabytes a large data set and the
reason why 50 terabytes was kind of the
magic number was because after that
volume the interactions between your
processing nodes the physical
reshuffling of data elements the
coordination between the workers was
just too much with the migration to the
data flow shuffle service you're now
able to shuffle much larger data sets
customers are reporting that they are
routinely shuffling hundred terabytes
and larger and the ceiling gets larger
and larger with every monthly release of
the service so this point I wanted to
show you demo in which I will quickly
join two data sets they're pretty large
data sets in total they constitute 100
terabytes worth of data my pipeline is
relatively simple I have two inputs the
our GCSE packets and each of these
buckets it's actually a single packet it
contains 50 thousand files one gigabyte
in size each and I'm gonna explain what
the contents of these files is very
shortly so these inputs are being joined
in my pipeline and I write the outputs
which is a join result set the results
out of a join again into GCSE buckets on
the right-hand side you see the code of
my pipeline I use Scala to develop this
pipeline and I also delight on a package
developed by one of our customers
Spotify this package is called sheer
makes it really easy to write pipelines
I'll quickly explain what happens in
this script if you focus on the main
function I'm defining my left and right
inputs that's my input 1 and input tour
I'm then doing a left outer join of one
of the inputs with the other input and
I'm saving the results of this left
outer join into a collection of files
each of the files in my input bucket has
three columns remember each file is one
gigabyte large and I have 50,000 files a
gigabyte in size so each of these files
has three columns the first column
represents the key by which I will be
joining my datasets the second column is
a sequential number that just iterates
through the records located in my input
file and then the third column is the
payload and if if I have a production
pipeline I would perhaps have a
serialized the presentation of a
business object here perhaps a sales
transaction or or a user clicking on a
webpage anything that makes sense to
your business so with this let me switch
to demo mode and show you how how easy
it is to initiate a dataflow job that
runs and users theta4 shuffle to shuffle
a really large data set in shell I've
done some prep work
and I've already uploaded all the files
in my input pockets I wanted to show you
the the command I will be using to
initiate data flow job
this command is using the Scala built
from this particular class file the demo
dot join and I am specifying a few
parameters here first off I'm gonna tell
the project in which I want to run this
job I also specified to the scalability
tool that I want to use my data flow
runner meaning I want the job to be
executed in the data flow service I'm
specifying my inputs and the inputs is
actually a shell variable which will
which will result in a filter kind of a
pattern that specifies about 58
terabytes worth of files and lastly I
have a command that specifies my my
shuffle operation so if you wanted to
know how to launch a shuffle job what
you need to know is just specify an
experiments flag and the flag says
shuffle mode equals service that's all
you need to do to run a shuffle job and
incidentally I also started the job just
by playing around with the parameters
it's all good in a few seconds you'll
see the results of this job submission
hopefully it will be a success
it usually takes between thirty to
thirty seconds just to send to send the
files back to the service before the
demo I've done some similar runs of 100
terabytes inside size so let me show you
the results of the jobs that I ran just
before the demo here's the collection of
the dataflow jobs that I ran previously
let me pick one and by the way already
my job is is not being being run by the
service but it's obviously not not
finished so let me still explore one of
the previous jobs has been successfully
executed everything is green here you'll
recognize the pipeline graph it takes
two inputs and produces an output
now just to show you how many data
elements this pipeline crunches through
I have fifty billion rows which will be
joined from each side of the join so
both the left
that's area the right and the left side
of the join will have 50 billion rows of
50 terabytes in size the the actual join
operation happens in what they call a co
group by key the this particular join
will create 100 billion groups of of the
same key and then the result of my of my
join will be persisted in a GCS bucket
it will actually be a collection a
logical action probably tens of
thousands of files and it will be almost
half a petabyte in size 2.5 trillion
records and half a petabyte of of data
so this entire join took me only a 7
hours to run seven and a half hours to
run the day before and during this
execution I was able to rely on data
flows distributed processing
capabilities by using a thousand workers
to run my my joining my region from
sources my joining and my outputting to
destinations here's a pipe line graph of
of the worker history that shows how
many workers were used during the
execution of this of this job
after a quick spike 2000 workers
dataflow maintained the number of
workers at a thousand the thousand here
is a kind of a magic number related to
my project my quota is limited to a
thousand workers and so this is why the
other flow didn't go above so for about
seven to eight hours a thousand workers
by crunching through these petabytes of
data and produced 2.5 million sorry
2.5 trillion output records
similar to this 100 terabyte run I also
did several similar runs but just
different in size and I've plotted the
graph that represents the duration of
these runs in relation to the size of
the joints so my one hand a terabyte Ron
is all the way up there in the upper
right corner and also have two
additional runs which differ from my
Hannah terabyte Ron in size and we I
always step down with by 5x reduction in
size so the 20 terabyte Ron ran 20
terabytes on ran for about 100 minutes
and the 4 terabyte Ron ran for probably
less than 20 minutes
as you can see data flow is able to
scale the execution time of my joins
pretty linearly depending on the data
set size which is a great quality of of
this particular raffled limitation
usually shuffle starts getting slower
and slower and becomes nonlinear when
you increase the data size the other
good quality of data flow shuffle is is
that the resources used for the
shuffling of of this data set also
scared linearly you don't see it in the
graph here but if you kind of reproduce
the results in your own tests you would
see that the shuffle resource is also
scaled linearly so so far we talked
about batch pipelines and how we do
shuffles in in batch jobs data flow
provides a unified batch and steaming
processing environment and you might ask
yourself well does this apply to
streaming pipeline as well to steaming
pipelines also need to be able to do
shuffle the answer is yes just like in
batch
streaming pipelines can also do
groupings and joins you can group and
join streams or you can group and join
streams and static snapshots and this
leads to a need to to have a distributed
streaming shuffle very similar arguments
apply here as we just discussed in the
batch case in steaming there's also
another consideration which is very
important
and that's the and that's the state of
your window time indoor storage I'm
going to explain what time windows are
and why we need to store data elements
related to these time windows but just
suffice to say to know that in streaming
customers typically want to aggregate
data elements based on some time
dimension some business time dimension
and we need to accumulate the data
elements related to individual time
windows in this time dimension until we
can actually process them let's take a
minute to review the life of a streaming
pipeline similarly to how we looked at
the life of a batch pipeline I have a PI
a pipeline that reads from pub/sub does
a windowing operation basically windows
my inputs team buy some business time
dimension then does a grouping of data
elements in France a aggregation
operation account in this case it
basically counts the number of elements
in a group and stores the results in
bigquery so let's focus on the group by
one thing to remember is in a steaming
pipeline once you submit the job to the
dataflow service we will divide the the
job the steaming job in into three
phases everything before the group I
everything after the group by and then
we will have the group i apprec which
will be implemented as a streaming
shuffle dataflow deals with very large
volumes of data and the way we deal with
these huge volumes of data is by
paralyzing work and doing the processing
on many many workers the way we
parallelized work is by dividing our
input datasets and kind of charging the
data input data inputs by key dividing
them by key and then assigning key
ranges to individual workers so these
key ranges become the basic unit of
scaling for us and we only assign and
redistribute work between processing
nodes by assigning
he arranges and this kiki rangers become
the become owned by a particular data
processing worker you might ask where do
we take the keys if you're steaming
pipeline has a group by key operation
will take the key that you specified
during the group by key if you don't
have a group by key will actually auto
generate keys and then partition them
into key ranges so let's let's take a
look what happens when when you start
your streaming job first off we'll
create a processing cluster of streaming
streaming workers they'll sign the keys
to each individual worker as you see
here the keys the bow of the before
shuffle operation and the keys of the
after shuffle operation are being
assigned to different workers and some
workers might get more work than others
well they're gonna store the keys and
the data elements the records associated
with these keys on persistent disk this
is how we currently do streaming shuffle
all of the information very similar to
current implementation of bad shuffle
before the shuffle service we are using
persistent disk volumes in both cases
and when we have to scale our steaming
pipeline when for example we start with
five processing workers but realized
that our data volume justifies the
increase of of this cluster to perhaps
ten processing workers what we're going
to do is we're going to start shuffling
the disks that store the key ranges that
contain the data records so the entire
data disk the entire PD disk will be
reassigned from one worker to another
and our steaming auto scaling
implementation works very well for many
cases but as you can imagine there's a
lot of shuffling of disks going on and
it might not be the fastest way to to
reassign work between processing workers
another thing to remember is that the
number of disks used in a streaming
pipeline in a current implementation of
shuffle and a steaming pipeline
so that number of desks is fixed and
it's determined at the beginning of the
pipeline we typically pick a very
reasonable number at the beginning but
then we never changed the number of
disks fully duration of the streaming
pipeline the only way for us to to give
more disks to a particular worker is
basically by taking and it's just an
existing disk from another worker so we
just covered how to do group bys and in
shuffle and streaming let's also look at
the window in operation because it's
quite central to the concept of a
streaming pipeline to understand what
happens during window and let's quickly
review what a data stream represents
typically customers have two important
time dimensions in their data streams
the first important time dimension is
the business time of the transaction
we call it the event time it typically
represents some business timestamp when
if you have a sales application when was
the sale done was at 8 a.m. 9 a.m. some
other time if you have a marketing
application when did the customer
interacted with your website so it's
it's the click time the other
interesting dimension in data processing
is the processing time so this is the
time when your data element actually
arrives at your processing pipeline and
interestingly event time and processing
time will always differ for pretty much
every data element in your stream and
here's why have an example of three
business transactions that that all
happened at the same business time so
the sale the sale happened at 8 a.m. my
green and my blue and my yellow data
element they all happened at the same
time now they actually arrived at
different time points in my steaming
pipeline you might just might ask
yourself why
for example a if the sale happened on a
mobile device that mobile device might
have had different bandwidth
capabilities and so as the racket was
traveling through the networking
infrastructure it took its time and got
delayed by almost
our perhaps another customer the
customer who submitted the the yellow
transaction was on a plane at that time
and so there was no connectivity and the
sale transaction actually didn't get
into a network and into your steaming
pipeline up until three three hours
later after it actually happened so this
is why event time and processing time
differs but users actually don't want to
deal with processing time this is not
what their business represents they want
to be able to deal with event time they
want to be able to take the input stream
and they bow they would like to be able
to divide it into nice windows based on
the event time and then run aggregation
operations based on time windows defined
on Aventine so now that we understand
how been doing works let's kind of
conclude and and explain how we store
these data elements until we can
actually do anything on them because
there's a difference between event time
and processing time we're gonna have to
cache and store temporarily data
elements related to time windows and we
are storing them again on persistent
disk just similar to hobby store shuffle
data so the persistent disk volumes have
have two functions here they will store
your shuffle data and they will store
temporarily the time in the data up
until the time when we see that no other
records related to a time in dough
arrived and we can trigger our
processing on these time windows the
data flow streaming engine is our
implementation on tail or shuffle button
streaming pipelines very similarly to
batch use cases we've asked ourselves
can we improve the processing of shuffle
in steaming cases and can we improve the
state storage the window state storage
for steaming the steaming engine moves
the processing of state as well as of
shuffle from the processing workers all
the way to our back-end service in and
in the process users get three benefits
first off they gain smoother auto
scaling we don't have to move for
possessing discs anymore the other
benefit is we can now do much better
maintenance of our operations we don't
have to shut down user pipelines we can
maintain our back-end infrastructure
without impacting customers and lastly
the user code that still runs on the
processing nodes we are not moving that
one it's so your user pipeline still
runs on a cluster of processing nodes
your code gets more resources because
the operations that you stir on the
system operations that used to run on
the same processing node have been moved
to a back-end service and now suddenly
your user code gets more memory and more
CPU let me give you an example of how
auto scaling was improved with the
streaming engine I have a stream of data
that I collected over a period of one
hour and that steam ranged from 1 to 10
million bytes per second and I have two
distinct spikes increases in this data
stream somewhere closer to the the first
third of the time period and then at the
end of the time period when I launch the
job a streaming job a streaming pipeline
without using the streaming engine I got
the following graph of the number of
workers that the dataflow Service
decided to use to process my data as you
would expect the the number of workers
initially was quite low I think it was
about 3 but then as the data increased
and as dataflow service realized that
the backlog was growing and we could
have used more resources Dena foe has
increased the number of workers all the
way to 15 and kept it at that number
until the intensity of my data stream
declined and we didn't need that many
resources anymore all the way up until
the end of the pipeline where the end of
the hour when the de steamer ate again
increased and we needed more resources
now compare this graph with the graph
with the of a streaming pipeline with
the streaming engine the first thing
you'll mention it or see will be that
the number of streaming workers that the
data for service will
at the first spike is going to be
smaller than in the previous graph and
I'm actually gonna overlay the two
graphs so that you see a little bit
better so data flow didn't need as many
workers to process your your data
because now your system operations such
as shuffle and state storage irani are
running on the back-end service your
user code gets more resources it has a
better throughput rate the other thing
that you will see from this graph is
that we are now able to much quicker
downsize the number of workers used in a
streaming pipeline we didn't need didn't
need to wait all the way until we we saw
the reduction in the data stream so just
to summarize let me wrap up in
transition to and try to answer a few
questions that some of you submitted
online the data flow team has learned
that using a distributed shuffle was
really the key component a really
architectural decision for an effective
separation of state storage and compute
processing we did this and the batch
pipelines we offered this capability in
streaming pipelines in batch we are
offering data flow shuffle and it allows
your batch pipelines to run faster and
scale to larger data sets in the
streaming case we have the steaming
engine which also leads to improvements
in auto scaling and also improvements in
separate ability these two features are
available in two GCP regions in your
central one and europe past one data
flow shuffle is now in general
availability and the streaming engine is
in beta if you would like to try both of
these features or data flow in general
please go to cloud google.com slash data
flow and you'll get all the information
you desire so with this stay tuned for
the Q&A we'll be back in just a minute
after reviewing the questions that we
are submitted I would be happy to answer
the questions you have
welcome back so we did get quite a few
questions here so let's go through them
the first one was how do I start using
the dataflow shuffle if you remember
from my demo
I used the the parameter that said
experiments equals shuffle mode equals
service that's all you need to do to
start using the dataflow shuffle feature
incidentally this is exactly the same
way you would specify just slightly
different parameter name
how would you specify the use of the
streaming engine in streaming engines
case you would say experiments equal
streaming engine equals a particular
value if you would like to know the
exact wording of these parameters just
go to the link I shared in the previous
slide cloud Google Chrome's large data
flow go to our dogs and you'll see the
parameters there right there you don't
have to change your code you only have
to change or specify a parameter in in
the submission of the pipeline the
second question is about api's are there
any special api is required to use
shuffle and steaming engine no special
api required you're still thinking in
terms of a directed cyclical graph you
write your dataflow pipelines using
either the Python or Java SDK using the
same commands same transforms that you
got here used to remember shuffle and
steaming engine will be used any time
and when you when you decide to use
these two components anytime you use a
core group by key or a group by key
these are the two operations which are
which use shuffle and steaming engine
the third question is about the size the
maximum size of data sets that a data
for shuffle operation can support 100
terabytes is not the maximum we've seen
customers doing much more than 100
terabytes so
as I mentioned before the the ceiling is
actually being increased every month
every quarter as we do improvements on
the service hopefully by this time next
year I'll be able to to add a digit to
this number
another question talks about whether you
can use the steaming engine without
using dataflow
so today the steaming engine and
dataflow service are kind of part of
this of a larger offering it's currently
not possible to use the streaming engine
without dataflow but it's an interesting
consideration is the streaming engine
free do you have to pay for the
streaming engine the steaming engine
does generate billable units actually in
both in the shuffle case and the
streaming engine case the the unit of
billing and the unit of usage is the
amount of bytes your process and run
through these services so they scale
very very linearly with the data sets
that you're trying to process the
feature is not free but it's very
reasonably priced and you can you can
get the pricing information by going to
the data flow page cloud google.com
slash dataflow slash pricing another
question talks about stateful processing
with a steaming engine can you do
stateful processing with the streaming
engine so this is something that I
didn't have to time to touch upon in in
the presentation in the webinar but
dataflow does have a state API and the
state API will actually work with the
streaming engine where the state will
now be stored not on the persistent
disks of your workers but on the backend
of our service so yes you can do
stateful processing there is a state API
for streaming pipelines and the last
question talks about joining streaming
data specifically can you join streaming
data with master data so a use case like
that would be you have a stream of sales
transactions and you have a what a
lookup table that converts from a string
value to a
value that he will then who's perhaps
for storing in a data warehouse their
answer is it's pretty easy to accomplish
such a sight we join in our terminology
I would recommend doing a sight input
side inputs allow you to define look-up
tables so look up datasets and as long
as they fit into memory of a single
worker maybe a gigabyte or several
gigabytes you do have the leverage of
being able to define different machine
sizes so as long as your data set is
reasonably large not measure that
terabytes perhaps gigabytes you can do a
very very fast in memory join of
streaming data with master data now if
your data set is large you you should
use the distinction that is enabled by
your specifying the co group by key
operation in your pipeline and with this
we be good for today thank you very much
for joining this webinar
I enjoyed sharing more about cloud
dataflow with your stay tuned for the
next webinar unlocking data analytics
and machine learning with bigquery ml